Speaker 1: It has been a wild 24 hours of news. We
will talk about the Tucker Carlson firing, the Don
Lemon firing. We will look at new interviews from
Ron DeSantis and Donald Trump showing what a very
ugly 2024 Republican primary might look like.
But the big news. Joe Biden announcing that he
is indeed running for reelection in 2024. If he
were to win, he would best his own record of the
oldest age to start a presidential term. Remember
that Joe Biden already the oldest president ever
to start a presidential term at 78 when he was
inaugurated in January of 2021. Second would,
of course, be Ronald Reagan at age 73. Joe Biden
would be 82, I believe if my math is right and
my recollection and my facts at the start of
a second term. But can he get there? Well,
that is, of course, a different question. The
New York Times headline today, Biden Announces
Reelection Bid Defying Trump and History. While
the president once pitched himself as a bridge to
a new generation of Democratic leaders, he has
decided that he is not ready to turn the torch
over yet. There may be an event sometime later
this week with another announcement. But for now,
this is the announcement and there is all sorts
of speculation that honestly, I will mention,
but I don't think is that useful to just really
dwell on everything from Biden doesn't really
plan to stay all the way to the election. This is
a placeholder because it would hurt him to say now
that he's not running for reelection, but he has
to say something because Trump's running at the
Santos might soon be getting in and he can't just
do nothing. But he's going to be a placeholder for
the eventual nominee when Biden bows out. Well, we
have no evidence that that's the plan. Of course,
you can always assert that someone is lying and
they have some real plan behind the scenes, but
we don't have evidence of that right now. Much of
this is driven, I think, by two things Joe Biden's
age. And again, the fact that he once did pitch
himself as a bridge, as a transitional president
who might only serve for one term if any of those
scenarios happen. We are going to have time to
discuss and to analyze, but it doesn't seem very
worthwhile to invest time in that right now. Now,
what I think is more interesting to look at is
where are the polls today and do Democrats want
Biden to run? Let's start with polling. There
is a plethora of polling, hypothetical polling
which says if it's Biden versus DeSantis or
if it's Biden versus Trump, what are people
saying right now? A new poll released today from
Ipsos Reuters has Biden ahead of DeSantis by nine
and Biden ahead of Trump by five. This
poll is out of step with other polling in
two ways. Number one, in most polling, Biden does
better against Trump than DeSantis. In this poll,
Biden does better against the
Santos. It's also different
in that the numbers are, you know, if you look at
most of these other polls we're talking about tied
all the way up to like plus four plus five and
plus nine is not something that we are seeing.
We similarly have another poll released two days
ago from Morning Consult, which has Biden plus
four over DeSantis and plus one over Trump. And
then a number of other poll polls in which Biden
does better against Trump than DeSantis. But the
early numbers and they are worth a little bit,
but not that much right now, are that Joe Biden,
for the most part, is polling ahead of the two
most likely Republican challengers in 2024. This
gets us to the third component of this discussion,
which is are voters happy with the most likely
choices, which are Biden and Trump? And the
answer is no, not really. And we talked about
this yesterday on the bonus show a little bit.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money. Sure. Everybody else
who makes money to fund themselves as bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah, we made money yesterday
on the bonus show talking about this. Majorities
don't want Biden and Trump to run in 2024. A new
NBC News poll found that 60% of Americans think
Trump should not try to retake the Oval Office,
including roughly a third of Republicans. At the
same time, 70% of Americans think Biden shouldn't
seek a second term, including 51% of Democrats.
A majority of Democrats don't believe Biden
would seek a second term. Now, what we spoke about
yesterday with producer Pat on the bonus show is.
Just because you would rather a different choice
doesn't mean if you're a Democrat, you're going to
vote for Trump or if you're a Republican, you're
going to vote for Biden. It doesn't mean that.
And I do think that all of the data points as to
if these are the choices, even if you'd rather
someone else, if you're not a Trump person, you're
not going to vote for Trump just because you'd
rather someone other than Biden and vice versa.
Now, I want to go one step further. You all know.
I've not been a Biden cheerleader. I don't find
Biden electrifying or exciting or any of it. But
I try to evaluate presidencies as objectively as
possible. And I'm going to have a deeper dive on
this for you soon. When I look on paper,
as the kids say, it's hard to argue that
the Biden presidency is anything but one of the
most successful presidential terms in a very long
time. I know. I know. Biden is not as left as I
would like and Biden was not the guy I supported
in the primary and all these different things.
But when you actually look at accomplishments,
particularly in the context in which Joe Biden
is serving this first of potentially two terms,
it is really difficult to say that this is
not a very successful presidential term.
It's crazy to think about. I will lay it
out for you as a non Biden cheerleader,
just looking to be as objective as possible.
Maybe we'll do that tomorrow or Thursday. Maybe
we'll give it a little more time and look at that
next week. But Joe Biden running for reelection.
We are going to be watching this election very
closely. We really are. You know, we have this
coupon code 24 starts now on our website. We
really are in the midst of the 2024 election
as quickly it feels like we're still seeing
Trump at 2 a.m. the day after the 2020 election
saying, I guess I won feels like it was
just yesterday. But we really are ramping
up here in the 2024 election and we're
going to be covering all of it for you.